voici un PC avec un écran 3 dimensions
sans lunettes ce qui fait que vous
regardez votre PC vous allez pouvoir
voir du contenu en 3D avatar par exemple
en 3D sans lunettes des films en 3D sans
lunettes et plein d'applications usage
médical pour venir travailler son
anatomie pour de l'industrie également
pour le commerce également pour
découvrir le vivant pour les architectes
mais également pour les enfants le truc
est vraiment génial parce que ça ouvre
plein de perspectives regardez là par
exemple là j'ai l'impression de caresser
l'antenne de l'abeille alors qu'en fait
l'écran il est hyper loin et ça c'est
vraiment très très bizarre c'est Asus
qui fait ça qui vous montre en techno
ici au CES avec un PC qui va sortir
cette année vous allez pouvoir faire
énormément de choses et pousser beaucoup
de limite la trois dimensions arrive
chez vous surtout sans lunettes ça
fonctionne avec deux caméras qui sont
directement sur votre pc chaque caméra
va venir suivre votre œil pour venir
superposer deux images et avoir un rendu
en trois dimensions perso j'adore et je
vous invite réellement à venir le tester
et découvrir en magasin parce que c'est
juste Dingo d'ailleurs dites moi ça
pourrait vous intéresser dans les
commentaires